- I am such a believer
in handwritten letters.
Pilot Pen is actually
our season long partner
because I love handwritten
letters so much.
Our world is more digital than ever
which makes physical
letters more important
and special than ever.
This next story proves
just that meet Amy and Dana
they met at summer camp, but lost touch
and they reconnected on Facebook.
But it wasn't until Dana's son had cancer
that Amy wrote her a
handwritten letter, and it led
to more letters and their
friendship was renewed
and also sparked a project
that connected hundreds
of other people.
But we're gonna get to that later.
Please welcome Dana and Amy, everybody.
- Thank you.
- So welcome to the show.
- Thank you so much for having us here.
- Yeah. You look beautiful.
- Thanks.
- I saw y'all in the lobby on the way in
and I was like, God, they look beautiful.
I love the colors.
So you were camp counselors?
Is that how y'all met?
- That's how we met.
We were Camp Olympia at Trinity, Texas
and we spent -
- Trinity, Texas?
- Yeah, we probably
spent two weeks together.
And you know how you just make
a connection with somebody?
- Yeah. Right away.
- We both have huge personalities.
And then so it was like bang.
We had a great time and then -
- I would love y'all.
- Then we spent, we
walked away and we spent
the next 30 years doing
life totally apart.
And I always had her name kind of kicking
around in my head and
wondered what happened to her.
I get on Facebook just like everybody else
I was like, boom, there's Dana.
And so, I friend request her
I found out right away, she
has five kids, four girls
and the youngest Parker, her only son.
And he has, you know, I
found out he had cancer.
And so we messaged back and forth.
I was like, I'm praying for
you, thinking about you.
And then when he relapsed, it was
like a bolt from God out of the sky.
It was like, you know what?
I'm a writer. I'm gonna
start writing him letters.
So the whole thing kicked off
when I started to write
Dana and Parker letters
at the Ronald McDonald House in Memphis.
- Oh wow.
What was your experience like
just hearing from her outta nowhere?
- Well, first of all,
I was kind of surprised
because we had not seen her,
you know, besides Facebook here
and there.
In so many years.
But then I was so touched because we got,
Parker and I got a lot
of support and gifts
and things like that.
But the difference with Amy
is that she kept writing.
She kept writing week after week.
And Parker was like, who is this woman?
And I'm like, someone
dad and I worked with at
at a camp years ago.
And he's like, how cool
though that she thinks enough
of us to write us every week.
- Yeah
- So she continued that.
And Parker fought a very brave battle.
He never complained.
And our worst day happened
in January of 2015.
And so we went home and there
was a letter in the mail
and the next week a letter,
and the next week a letter.
Amy continued to write me.
So finally I wrote her back.
And it was just such a great
thing. We became pen pals.
I was able to share my
grief in a safe space.
And it wasn't just myself
that started looking forward
to her letters, my family
would say, did it come yet?
You know, every week it, it
just made such a difference.
She still writes me every single week.
- Oh my gosh. I love it.
Oh, try not to cry.
Okay. Wait, Amy, so you
had an epiphany from this,
so what was it?
- Well, this free space was created
between the two of us where
I did a lot of sharing too.
And it just impacted me profoundly.
And I was like, you know what?
If I can have this one
random girl in Louisiana
this one Facebook friend
just blow up my life,
what else is out there?
So I was like I'm gonna write
all the 580 of these people.
So I don't know that I thought
I was really gonna do it.
- Wait 580, what people,
where'd you get that number?
- Facebook friends.
- Oh, that's how many
friends you have on Facebook?
- That's what I had.
- Oh my God.
Okay. I'm like, I don't, I'm not on.
So I don't know.
But I'm just like, that's a lot.
- Yeah, no, it was a lot.
So I put all the names in a box.
- It's a lot of pen and paper mam.
- I started pulling those names out
and it just blew up my
life because you know
I wrote to a girl who helped
me when my grandmother died
I wrote to my seventh grade band friend.
I wrote to a guy I dated in college.
I wrote to a girl I danced
with at a wedding, you know?
And then all these people
that just were names
on a list, I was like, you
know what it really is?
I'm connected to this treasure
full of amazing people.
And there's just so much hope in that.
- Yeah. And connecting with
people and those relationships
that's really what life is about.
The older we get, we realize
it's that simple right?
- Right. Exactly.
- Yeah. And that connection is so cool.
And so the letter is turned
into even more writing.
So tell us about the book.
Right. Well, I was about three quarters
through writing up 600 letters.
And I was like, you know what?
We got a special story here
with so much hope in it.
I was like, I'm gonna write a book.
And so the book is called Dear Dana
that time I went crazy
and wrote all 580 of my
Facebook friends a letter.
The longest subtitle in history.
- That's the most amazing title.
- And so it takes those two narratives.
So it takes Dana and I's story
and a lot of Dana's words are in it.
You know, our pen paling at the beginning
and then it runs the Facebook
letter story through that.
And we went on a book tour
this summer, you know, going
on a book tour with your best
friend, 17 different cities.
And one of the best things
was people showed up over
and over again, Facebook
friends, people of that 580
with their letter in
pristine, you know, condition.
They're like, like they were a rockstar
cause they had this letter.
And they kept them in special places.
And it's just another
illustration how something
like a deliberate act, like a
handwritten letter can really
it really can change someone's life.
- Absolutely. Yeah. Well,
we shared this story
with Pilot Makers of FriXion
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
And they love celebrating
those who create fearlessly
and of handwriting 580 letters.
Isn't that, I don't know what it is.
So Pilot wanted to do
something to honor Parker.
So they're making a $5,000 donation to
St. Jude Children's Research
Hospital in his name.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- Thank you Pilot. That's amazing.
- It's a hard thing I can't
even imagine going through.
But I do love that
something beautiful came
out of it and something
positive that is connected
to Parker, you know?
- Absolutely.
- So that will go on
forever, which is beautiful.